hi i'm brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords the founder of
certified knowledge
and the ppc faculty chair for market
noda in this lesson we're going to give
a brief overview of paid search
advertising
the paid search advertising is also
called pay-per-click advertising or
abbreviated as ppc advertising
sometimes you'll also hear it called cpc
or cost per click advertising as well
at a high level the way this works
is that you choose who can see your ad
this could be based upon geographic
characteristics a keyword chosen a topic
selection so forth
next you set a bid for what you're
willing to pay for a click
paid search advertising is an auction
based system so you can set a bid based
upon what you're willing to pay for a
click
next when someone meets your targeting
criteria your ad can be displayed now if
that user clicks on your ad then you pay
up to your bid price you may pay lower
than your bid price as well
finally when someone clicks on your ad
the searchers taken to your website
so if you've ever seen ads on google or
bing these are paid search ads
now one of the true advantages of paid
search advertising is that there's no
wasted impressions when you look at
radio advertising television advertising
and other mediums they're known as
interruptive marketing
you stop someone from watching a
television commercial
you show an ad copy
after the commercial is over someone can
return to the content
because you're displaying this ad to
everyone who can see the content there's
a lot of people who aren't interested in
your ad they don't care about your
message they use remote control they
switch stations during commercials with
paid search advertising
since you're targeting someone based
upon user criteria whether it's a search
query they've conducted whether it's a
specific site there on so forth there's
no wasted ad impressions your ads are
always relevant
this leads us to the three r's a
pay-per-click advertising
first is reach this is where can the ad
be seen
second is relevance how useful is the ad
to the
user and finally return investment
how can you measure advertising
effectiveness so we're going to look at
the three components of paid search
first to reach where are these ads seen
well they can be seen on bing yahoo ask
google aol
many other places
advertising on search engines gives you
a huge amount of reach
google processes about 34 000 searches a
second so number of potential
impressions is staggering when that's
just one search engine when you add bing
yahoo and other engines
to the possibilities of reach
the reach is an impressive number of how
many people can potentially see your ad
however these paid search ads go beyond
just search sites
there's more than a million partners
just on google's display network
so even on content based sites about.com
new york times how stuff works the food
network
these ads can also be seen
and you can choose which of these sites
you want to be on and how your ads are
displayed on display sites as well
in fact beyond search engines there's
also other types of pages advertising
you can do
youtube linkedin facebook
so the reach of paid search is
impressive reach what's important is to
understand how to control the reach so
you can target your specific user base
if you have an ideal customer profile
you can look to see what your customer
does online
and target the customers based upon
their behavior
now reach goes beyond just the desktop
you have ads on tablets ads on mobile
devices in app ads
so regardless of how someone's accessing
the internet you can serve ads to those
users based upon
their behavior
the second component a paid search is
relevance
if an ad isn't relevant to the user
users don't care about the ad very much
the fact when people are surveyed and
asked a simple question
do you mind advertising if it's relevant
to you
many more say no they're okay with
advertising if it's relevant
what we don't like to see is
non-relevant advertising
now to give an example of how relevant
you can be just using google
you can serve an ad to a user based upon
these
behaviors
first they search for online advertising
next they're sitting in new york city
they're using an ipad
it's a monday morning it's between 10
and noon
now that's a very targeted ad copy
you may not use every potential behavior
however
you can also consider paid search as
restrictive advertising
overall google processes a 100 billion
queries a month
that's a lot
so maybe this one is
advertised for the word online
advertising
lowers your query total 100 million a
month
then you say adjust the united states
your court holds down to 20 million a
month
and say while they're in new york city
your query total now is about 500 000 a
month
they're using an ipad
down about 8 000 a month
on a monday morning about a thousand
searches a month between ten and twelve
about a hundred searches a month
so paid search has a high relevance on
search pages
but even on content sites also known as
display advertising you can be just as
specific about the user behavior
you can target an ad for display
advertising assuming someone's on the
new york times
they're in the travel section of the new
york times
they're reading about caribbean
vacations
while in the travel section on the new
york times
they're located in minneapolis
using a computer
and it's a weekend
between 12 and 6 o'clock so targeting
options with paid search
exceed every other advertising medium
out there
now often people talk about paid search
you think of text ads you think of the
ads on the top of google search page or
bing search page there are other ad
formats
there are video ads image ads app-based
ads
so it's not just text ads
that can be used
there's a lot of other ad formats based
upon how you wish to portray your
message to the consumer
now finally with paid search you choose
where the customer goes after the click
so often when someone gets to your site
they arrive at your home page
the first thing they have to do
is look around search find your
navigation
to find
the relevant information on your site to
whatever their question is why they did
a search
with paid search you can choose what
page you're sending the traffic to
so you can have a page dedicated
to that user behavior whether it's their
search query the site they're on so
forth
and make custom messages on your website
that connect back to your ad
now the final r
in the three hours of paid search is
return on investment you have access to
powerful metrics
if you do not have access to data you're
blind
to how your ads are performing
when you buy ads on tv it's really hard
to measure how many sales you got from
that ad
however online
it's very transparent you can see your
goal types your conversion types whether
it's a phone call an e-commerce
transaction a form fill so forth
so you have access to the data
determine who is converting
what's making them convert
so you can continue to refine your ad
serving
and increase your online advertising
efficiencies
now paid search is often an auction
based system you'll set a bid up to how
much you're willing to pay for any one
click
now what you'll find is that different
targeting behaviors lead to different
overall conversion metrics
therefore you can set bids by every
keyword you're targeting or topic you're
targeting site your ad is placed on
based upon having access to the data to
understand the true value of what a
visitor is worth to you so that as your
advertising every click is profitable
that you're not wasting ad spend
every company should have a paid search
account
what are you trying to accomplish with
marketing
drive customers to your store sell
products online
generate more product demand increase
brand recognition just get more visitors
to your website
receive leads for the sales force
increase your newsletter subscriptions
have prospects call you instead of
outbound calling
if any one of these looks attractive to
you
then you should have a paid search
account
so paid search account will help you
meet these goals
so essentially we're moving the guessing
game
when you buy ads in a newspaper you have
to wait at least a week before you can
change your ad copy if you buy ads and
yellow pages you have to wait a year to
see what works
paid search gives you quick access to
data to determine what marketing
messages what ads what web pages
are leading to revenue
and customer actions on your site
ppc also gives you other valuable
insights
you can use keyword metrics to direct
your search engine optimization efforts
often with seo
you choose some words
you spend a few months attempting to
rank for those words
and the worst case scenario is you
finally rank for them and they don't
lead to customer interaction
and sales on your site
since you get such quick access to
conversion data you can use your paid
search information to help direct your
seo efforts
you can test display ads for print media
since there are display ads image based
ads
across page search if you're going to do
print media
and you don't want to wait a year to see
how your ad did test out display ads
unpaid search
use that information to help determine
what your ads look like for print media
even if one is data mined for customer
insights
what's most important to your customers
what benefits what features what message
is most important
paid search will help you get the data
so you can
mine your information
to get better insight into your customer
base
if you're looking for new marketing
messages because a paid search you can
quickly get feedback about what ad
copies are working
you can try a few different types of
marketing messages
and see what actually works and leads to
revenue
just want to see
how people interact with your video
online video usage is staggering
most people online are watching several
hours of video every single month
well you don't want to produce a video
and spend a lot of money making one
if it's not going to lead to interaction
and ultimately more sales so you can
even test video ads to see
what images within the video what
messages within the video also lead to
interaction on your site even if you
just want to name books i know
publishers before they name a book they
run paid search ads it's essentially the
ad with the highest click-through rate
how people are viewing an ad versus
clicking on it often corresponds to the
best poll rate off a shelf inside a
bookstore
so whenever you want insights
you want rapid feedback
paid search is useful
for getting information